PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUING HIS
VISIT TO    TO THE U.K. TODAY HV
VISIT TO    TO THE U.K. TODAY HN
VISIT TO    TO THE U.K. TODAY HG
VISIT TO    TO THE U.K. TODAY HA
GREAT RAPPORT WITH
PRIME MINISTER MAY AND HERE HE
IS SHARING A LIGHTHEARTED MOMENT
ABOUT HE MIGHT HAVE APPROACHED
BREXIT.
>> THAT IS OKAY.
I WOULD HAVE SUED AND SETTLED,
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW.
SHE IS PROBABLY A BETTER
NEGOTIATOR THAN I AM.
SHE HAS GOT IT IN A SENSE.
THE DEAL WAS TEED UP.
IT REALLY TEED UP.
I THINK THEY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
PERHAPS YOU WILL BE GIVEN THE
CREDIT IF YOU DO SOMETHING.
>> Dana: HE, HE FOUGHT BACK
AGAINST SOME CRITICS COME HERE
HE IS LIMNING THE MAYOR.
>> I THINK HE HAS BEEN A NOT
VERY GOOD MAYOR FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
HE HAS DONE A POOR JOB, A LOT OF
CRIME AND PROBLEMS AND I DON'T
THINK YOU SHOULD BE CRITICIZING
A REPRESENTATIVE OF
UNITED STATES THAT CAN DO SO
MUCH GOOD FOR THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE.
HE SHOULD BE POSITIVE, NOT
NEGATIVE.
HE IS A NEGATIVE FORCE NOT A
POSITIVE FORCE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE SAID HE
HURTS THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
HE SHOULD ACTUALLY FOCUS ON HIS
JOB.
IT WOULD BE BETTER IF HE DID
THAT.
HE COULD STRAIGHTEN OUT SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS HE HAD AND SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT HE HAS CAUSED.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT'S
REBUTTAL WHERE HE CALLED THE
MAYOR A STONE COLD LOSER.
>> IT SOMETHING YOU EXPECT FROM
AN 11-YEAR-OLD.
IT'S FOR HIM TO DECIDE HOW HE
WANTS TO BEHAVE.
IT'S NOT FOR ME TO RESPOND.
IT'S BENEATH ME TO DO CHILDISH
TWEETS.
I'M NOT OFFENDED IN THE
SLIGHTEST.
PEOPLE TELL ME, I THINK THIS
PRESIDENT AS IT SHOULD SURPRISE
YOU.
>> Dana: THE MEDIA IS MAKING A
BIG DEAL OVER PROTESTS IN THE
STRAIT OF LONDON WHERE THE UP
ERIC TRUMP BLUE AND MADE ITS
RETURN.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS, POSSIBLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS ARE
EXPECTED TO GATHER HERE TODAY
AND NOT AGAINST AMERICA, AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT AND THE VISIT HERE
TO THE U.K.
>> THERE ARE A FEW THOUSAND
PEOPLE GATHERED HERE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROTESTING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP >> WE SAW
POSSIBLY 10,000 HERE, UNITED IN
THEIR MESSAGE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN POLITICAL
REASONS BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
SEE HIM HERE.
>> THERE ARE QUITE A LOT ON
PROTESTERS.
THEY ARE ALL CHANTING AGAINST
TRUMPETS AND THEY DON'T WANT HIM
HERE.
THIS LOOKS LIKE TENS OF
THOUSANDS.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED TO THAT CALLING IS
FAKE NEWS.
>> AS PART OF THE PROTEST I HAVE
TO TELL YOU BECAUSE I COMMENTED
ON IT YESTERDAY, WE LEFT THE
PRIME MINISTER AND THE QUEEN,
THE ROYAL FAMILY AND THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS CHEERING AND EVEN COMING
OVER TODAY THERE WERE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE CHEERING AND THEN I
HEARD THAT THERE WERE PROTESTS
AND I SAID WHERE?
I DON'T SEE THEM.
I SAW A SMALL PROTEST, VERY
SMALL.
A LOT OF IT IS FAKE NEWS I HATE
TO SAY.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT ON THE
THE FIRST LADY HOSTING A DINNER,
WE GET TO SEE IT THERE.
THE FIRST LADY AND HER GOWN,
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE MEDIA AND BRITAIN LOVED TO
GONE ON A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: THEY ARE ABOUT SIX
MONTHS BEYOND THE AMERICAN
MEDIA, THEY'RE LIKE PARENTS AT A
LITTLE LEAGUE GAME AND THE
PROTESTERS ARE LIKE THE KIDS IN
THE GAME AND THEY HOPE THEY CAN
PLAY HARDER INTO A BETTER JOB
BUT THEY BUILD UP THE
EXPECTATIONS AND TURN ON THE TV
AND IT'S NOT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
WE HAVE TO DO THE TIGHTER SHOTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THERE AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE MAYOR WHO HAS
A SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH STABBINGS
IN HIS CITY, LAST YEAR IT WAS
LIKE 15,000 STABBINGS.
THEIR MURDER RATE IS SIMILAR TO
NEW YORK.
THEY DON'T HAVE GUNS.
I CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
IS HE A BANKER OR AN ANCHOR?
>> Dana: THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION.
>> Greg: FOR SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
BECAUSE IT IS ENGLAND I WOULD
LIKE TO PARAPHRASE CHARLES
DICKENS, MAY I?
ONE SIZE SEES THIS AS THE WORST
OF TIMES ON THE OTHER WHICH
INCLUDES ME SEES THIS AS THE
BEST OF TIMES.
IF YOU ARE STILL REACHING OR
REACTING EMOTIONALLY TO THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRIGGERS OF HIS
PERSONALITY THAN THIS WILL
ALWAYS BE THE WORST OF TIMES FOR
YOU.
IT'LL BE THE WORST OF TIMES FOR
ANOTHER SIX YEARS, BUT IF YOU
STEP BACK AND SEE THE TRIGGERS
ARE SMALL AND ENTERTAINING
THINGS THEN YOU SEE IT AS THE
BEST OF TIMES BECAUSE I WOULD
RATHER TAKE INSULTS OVER ISIS.
INSULTS WITH THE MAYOR ON THE
FRONT PAGE.
I WOULD RATHER TAKE A GIANT
BALLOON AND THE SKY THAN
NORTH KOREA THREATENING TO DROP
A BOMB.
I WILL TAKE A MEDIA DISDAIN FOR
A PRESIDENT OVER A LONG,
ECONOMIC BOOM.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE COVERED MANY
PRESIDENCIES AND I WONDER WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS.
EVEN REAGAN GOT RIDICULED BY THE
BRITS BACK THEN.
THE LOCAL MEDIA AND BRITAIN HAS
BEEN PRETTY POSITIVE ABOUT THIS
TRIP.
>> Juan: PRETTY POSITIVE ABOUT
THE WAY HE HAS DEALT WITH THE
ROYAL FAMILY.
THEY HAVE NOT SHARED THE VIEW
THAT THIS IS FAKE NEWS.
HE IS LIKE NO, I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY.
HE THINKS A HELICOPTER TO DINNER
AND COME HE DIDN'T DRIVE THROUGH
THE STREETS.
HE SAYS FAKE NEWS.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT FAKE NEWS BUT
THIS IS AGAIN LIKE THE ARGUMENT
WITH THE MAYOR, I THINK HE HAS
ELEVATING THE MAYOR BY ENGAGING
THE MAYOR AND THEN HE GIVES THEM
A PLATFORM AND HE IS DOING
INTERVIEWS.
I DON'T SEE HOW THAT HELPS THE
PRESIDENT, BUT AGAIN I AM
PUZZLED.
IT SEEMS LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
VERSUS MEGHAN MARKLE.
I NEVER SAID THAT, THE TAPE
SHOWS THAT HE SAID THAT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE
REINTERPRETING IT WRONG.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY.
HE DIDN'T SAY SHE WAS NASTY.
YOU KNOW THIS!
I LISTENED TO THE QUOTE.
>> Juan: HE SAYS I DIDN'T
KNOW.
>> Greg: SHE WAS REFERRING TO
HIS COMMENTS!
I AM REACTING TO YOUR LIVE.
>> Juan: IT'S MEGHAN MARKLE,
TWO IT'S TRUMP VERSUS THE G.O.P.
TODAY IN TERMS OF THE
CONGRESS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, THE ONLY
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE BEEN LOYAL
SAYING WE CAN TAKE THE TARIFFS
AND OF COURSE IT'S TRUMP VERSUS
THE MAYOR OF LONDON.
IT JUST GOES ON.
YOU SAY THIS IS AN TRIGGERING?
>> Greg: THE GOLDEN AGE BABY.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE HAD THE U.S. AND
THE U.K. SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP,
THESE MEETINGS LIKE IS THIS
GOING TO BE OKAY?
EVERYTHING IS OKAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT PROVIDED A LOT
OF COVER FOR THERESA MAY.
SHE IS A LAME DUCK
PRIME MINISTER AND ON HER WAY
OUT THE DOOR.
ALSO PUSHING BACK ON THE MEDIA
BECAUSE IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE PROTESTERS AND SOME OF THE
LOCAL REPORTING A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE JUST PROTESTING FOR
THEIR OWN CAUSES ALTOGETHER AT
ANTI-DROP RALLY.
THEY'LL HAVE THEIR ANTIWAR,
WOMEN'S RIGHTS GROUPS, ALL
COMBINED TOGETHER SO YOU LOOK AT
THIS, THAT'S NOT ANTI-TRUMP,
THEY'RE JUST PROTESTING TO
PROTEST.
THEY WERE DECEIVING WHEN IT CAME
TO THAT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS MORE
DIPLOMATIC THAN HE EVER WAS.
>> Dana: I THINK YOU WAS
WELCOMED AND THAT HE WAS ENJOYED
AND EMBRACED.
THE QUEEN IS SUPER CHARMING AND
HE FEELS LIKE HE WAS
SUFFICIENTLY WELCOMED.
>> Greg: THIS IS LIKE WHEN HE
IS A BOY AT HIS BEST BEHAVIOR AT
A FORMAL DINNER.
>> Dana: EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
GOING QUITE WELL.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Emiyl: THIS IS REFLECTIVE
OF THE MEDIA PUSHING A NARRATIVE
THAT DOESN'T EXIST YET OR MAY BE
EXIST IN A LOWER CAPACITY.
WHEN HE SAID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS ARE EXPECTED BUT HE
WASN'T REFLECTING WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THAT MOMENT.
THEY ARE FOCUSING ON THE
SALACIOUS ASPECT AND YOU ARE
POINTING OUT THAT IT WAS
DIFFERENT MESSAGES.
THE WHOLE POINT WAS THAT THIS IS
THE 75TH ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY.
THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT OUR
PRESIDENT WAS INVITED FOR THE
THIRD TIME BY THE ROYAL FAMILY.
IT WAS THIS LARGER RELATIONSHIP
AND SITUATION HAPPENING AND THIS
IS CERTAINLY NOT EITHER THE
MONARCHS OR THE PRIME MINISTER'S
FIRST RODEO.
THE OFFICE OF THE PRIME MINISTER
AND FOR EVERYONE TO REDUCE IT TO
JUST AGAIN THAT SALACIOUS NATURE
I THINK MISSES THE WHOLE POINT.
IT'S ABOUT SOMETHING SO MUCH
LARGER.
BACK TO MY POINT YESTERDAY, YES
HE IS BENEATH THE OFFICE AND NOT
AT THE SAME LEVEL AS THE HEAD OF
STATE BUT IT'S A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY GIVEN AND 2016 HE
SAID HE WOULD LOVE TO SHOW THEN